what is up everybody at Santa Mac and
welcome to another installment of the
week's best anime videos where you can
come to catch up on all the good stuff
that you missed in the past week the
links to all the videos are in the
description and if you have a
recommendation just leave it in the
comments this past tuesday aki dearest
uploaded her latest d rocky video with
joey playing the role of doom and they
talked about some interesting stuff in
this one they talked about urea nice a
lot and they even gave a shout out to
some unknown youtuber let's see what
they said I am trying to reside in Japan
for good the process is a little complex
to explain but we are in the process of
that but yes I would totally stay here I
mean granted i've had allergies but i
think that my body's been getting used
to it still regardless japan i would
love to stay here yeah you heard it from
the woman herself put that in your anime
top weekly videos you've been noticed
that avail for we know what you do yeah
you know what I'm gonna be nice right
now go guys goes to subscribe to animate
uproar because he keeps up with a lot of
our stuff and he actually makes some
pretty cool video and he seems like cool
dude we did it mom and dad we did it
whoa wait we're still gonna shoot the
video right but just to get a bit
serious for a minute I've actually been
watching okies videos for about a year
and she's such a funny and entertaining
youtuber and yet she has this unique
ability to turn around and then talk
about really serious issues in a very
much her way which is really rare among
youtubers and I think she's gonna get
really far and my brother and I have
been watching the anime man for even
longer for like three years and before
we even considered making videos of our
own our two biggest influences were the
anime man and giggle I first started
making these weeks best videos because I
watch a lot of anime videos myself so I
wanted to help anyone who is interested
to catch up on any good videos that they
might have missed in the past week the
other reason I decided to do these
weekly videos is because I wanted to
force myself to sit down and make videos
every week so I can get more comfortable
in front of the camera it is it working
is it is it working I never thought that
someone like a key or joy would actually
notice these videos but it just goes to
show you how much they actually pay
attention to their fans and care about
their fans and that is not just pretty
cool it's pretty freaking cool but yeah
I don't know there was that much other
news this week oh yeah except the [ __ ]
called Geass
is getting a season three that's right
code geass is getting a third season a
sequel with Lelouch returning as the
main character obviously this is huge
news code geass is such an iconic anime
and I personally couldn't even believe
it i have to like triple check at
quadruple check it to make sure it's
really true but it is true code geass is
coming back for season 3 you cocka made
a video about this whole thing where he
talked about the news how crazy it is
and what our expectations should be and
I definitely recommend checking this
video up in fact just yesterday I made a
video called top three reasons Lelouch
is still alive where I sought to prove
once and for all that Lelouch was alive
at the end of our to and that is why
they're able to bring him back now for a
third season if that is something you're
interested in if you want to check out
the evidence for why Lelouch is still
alive the link is in the description and
for all of you Naruto fans ki cook just
uploaded another video today in which he
argues that Naruto actually has some of
the best fights in anime fun fact did
you know that the real reason why Sasuke
and Naruto fought is because they call
each other's mom's slags whatever that
means yeah it's all there in the video
check it out seriously though you should
probably check out every video that we
cook makes because he's such a great
content creator keep it up bro this past
Thursday we streamed the second episode
of r & cafe right here on our channel
and we had a great time talking about
the huge code geass news and also about
old anime versus new anime our special
guest this week we're Mackle not simply
rose an all-day anime and if you missed
the live stream you can still watch the
full video just follow the link below
and don't forget that a new episode of
rain cafe is gonna be streamed this
thursday at five p.m. eastern standard
time with special guest smackle not all
day anime and Brynn's fandoms our hot
topic for this week is going to be best
and worst anime characters so bring your
coffee bring your tea bring your maple
syrup and come hang out with us it's
gonna be a blast forneverworld uploaded
a video this week in which he talked
about how underpaid manga creators
really are he actually seems seriously
upset about this issue about how
underappreciated and underpaid manga
creators really are and he talks about a
lot of interesting issues within the
industry at the moment if you're
interested in the manga industry
definitely check out this video geekdom
one-on-one uploaded a video this week
about his top 10 favorite dragon ball z
episodes this was a very good list and I
grew up watching dragonball z as a kid
so this list really
took me back to the days when I got
super excited for all of these episodes
if you're still a big fan of Dragon Ball
Z or you just want to reminisce about
your childhood definitely check out this
video and my favorite AMV this week was
an origami and Lee called save me by a
youtuber called mighty amvs it had great
quality awesome visuals and just overall
an excellent AMV experience and that's
it for this week guys and wow this was
already our 10th episode I've actually
decided I'm going to do a year's best
anime videos episode at the end of the
year so you can start sending me your
recommendations right now what were your
favorite anime videos this year did you
like shelter Aki and Joey confessing
their love re zero in eight minutes let
me know in the comments because I'd love
to hear from you and until next time see
you space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]